ist das heute der tag der sich in das
kollektive gedächtnis der menschheit als
der historische tag aller zeiten ein
brennen wird die entdeckung von
außerirdischen leben heute am 14 09 2010
20 um 17 uhr mitteleuropäischer
sommerzeit verkündete die royal
astronomical society
diese wirklich absolut bahnbrechende
sensation auf der venus wurde eine
unglaubliche entdeckung gemacht absolut
unglaublich wie auch die geschichte der
entdeckung klicks und 20 user gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke denn nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
clixoom gibt es übrigens auch auf die
ohren der link ist hier unter me und in
der video beschreibung der physiker
enrico fermi hatte 1950 das thema auf
den tisch gebracht und zwar auf einem
weg zum mittagessen als einem gespräch
mit einigen seiner kollegen über ufo
sichtung und die existenz von
außerirdischen überhaupt war am ende so
heißt es soll er dann gesagt haben wo er
ist everybody dass wir trotz intensiver
suche keinerlei spuren von
außerirdischen leben finden sei einfach
nur paradox seitdem wundern sich
forschungsteam weltweit warum wir
einfach keine spuren von außerirdischen
finden
denn falls sie existieren müssten wir
dann nicht über hinweise zu ihnen nur so
stolpern
dem ist aber nicht so doch die suche
wird immer weiter intensiviert mit city
der search auf extraterrestrial
intelligence suchen wir in den signalen
aus dem all nach spuren von intelligenz
auf dem mars suchen rover nach spuren
von leben und haben immerhin metern
aufgespürt das auch durch organismen
produziert werden kann und die werte des
gases in der atmosphäre schwanken
ein zeichen für leben doch was jetzt auf
der venus entdeckt wurde ist absolut
sensationell denn dieses moleküle kann
unter den dortigen bedingungen nur durch
lebende organismen produziert werden es
ist nicht bekannt wie es dort ohne
biologisches leben entstehen kann
mono verfahren entdeckt haben es
forschende der cardiff university der
university of manchester und das
massachusetts institute of technology
mit hilfe des james clerk maxwell
teleskop auf hawaii und das atacama
large millimeter array alma das von der
europäischen südsternwarte eso betrieben
wird und sie haben sich jahrelang die
köpfe zermartert wie dieses molekül
anders zu erklären ist als durch
außerirdisches leben foto chemischen
prozesse chemische prozesse verursacht
durch die hohen temperaturen chemische
prozesse angestoßen durch die chemische
zusammensetzung der venus oberfläche
es gibt keine andere erklärung die
antwort ist jedes mal nein es geht nur
mit biologischem leben jedenfalls nicht
in der gefundenen menge von 20 molekülen
pro eine milliarde boni kühle es sind so
viele und diese moleküle wurden in einem
bereich der atmosphäre von in dem nach
heutigen erkenntnissen auf der venus
noch lebend zu finden sein könnte noch
forschende haben nämlich schon vor
jahren herausgefunden dass die
bedingungen auf der venus früher viel
lebensfreundliche waren und das ist
wirklich eine kuriose vorstellung die
venus mit einer deutlich kühleren
oberfläche als heute und zudem noch
bedeckt von zahlreichen ozean genau
davon geht eine studie eines
forschungsteams aus wales aus demnach
könnte der planet tatsächlich eine ganze
zeit lang äusserst lebensfreundliche
umweltbedingungen geboten haben venus
soll in diesem stadium sogar der erde
ziemlich ähnlich gewesen seien zusammen
mit experten und expertinnen der nasa
und forschungs kolleginnen und kollegen
aus washington führte das team
simulationen an einem numerischen
gezeigten modell durch hierbei wurde vor
allem der einfluss potenzieller ozeane
unterschiedlicher tiefe auf die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit des planeten
unter die lupe genommen und wie die
fachleute aus wales in der studie
schreiben haben die ozeane der venus
damals wie eine art bremse auf die
rotationsgeschwindigkeit des planeten
gewirkt die vorhandenen ozeane haben
dafür gesorgt dass sich die drehung der
venus deutlich verlangsamt vereinfacht
gesagt ist dies auf die reibung
zurückzuführen die bei flut und ebbe
zwischen einem ozean und dem meeresboden
wird sprich damals könnten die
temperaturen angenehm und
lebensfreundlich gewesen sein und wasser
hätte es demnach auch zu genüge gegeben
und das jetzt gefundene molekül stützt
die vermutung massiv dass dort auch
tatsächlich lebende organismen weiterhin
existieren es gibt einfach keine andere
erklärung um die moleküle zu finden
haben die forschenden untersucht welche
radio wellenlängen von der venus
reflektiert und welche absorbiert werden
und genau in der wellenlänge die mofas
fahren absorbieren würde
die radiowellen absorbiert das mono
fonds fahren also gefunden
die beteiligte professor und saga sieger
schilderte während der präsentation
heute eine mögliche lebensform und die
erinnerte verdammt an bärtierchen
demnach würde die spezies zwischen
lebensfreundlichen und nicht
lebensfreundlichen schichten der
atmosphäre zirkulieren in den heißen
unteren schichten würde sie dehydrieren
also wasser verlieren und in eine art
starre verfallen und dann wieder in den
oberen schichten wiederbelebt werden
eine existenz die genauso die
bärtierchen führen sie wechseln in
absoluter darin eine tönchen phase in
der sie praktisch tot sind es gibt keine
lebenszeichen aus der erwachen sie
wieder wenn die umgebung
lebensfreundlich ist so können sie in
absoluter trockenheit und sogar im
weltraum überdauern und dann wieder zum
leben erweckt werden ist das tatsächlich
das weltraum start das space spa über
das manche forschende spekulieren und
werden wir es auf der venus finden genau
das ist jetzt der plan sonden sollen zur
venus geschickt werden um dort nach
leben in der oberen atmosphäre zu suchen
es bleibt wahnsinnig spannend und wir
halten euch hier auf dem laufenden
heutige höllen landschaft gab es leben
auf der venus anklicken anschauen und
diesen kanal hier abonnieren wenn ihr
mehr über die mögliche entdeckung von
außerirdischen leben erfahren wollt bis
dann bleibt dran